good morning John and is Monday May 3rd
it is our dads birthday but I know that
dad doesn't want us to make a big deal
out of the fact that he is oh so I will
be talking about how and he was born the
most popular television show was uh oh
well it's silicon transistors or even
that soon both of his sons will be old
oh I know what dad really wants he wants
me to talk about net neutrality the
Internet is a series of tubes but for
the purposes of this demonstration the
internet is going to be my shower which
which is kind of the tube the internet
it flows into my house this water this
nourishing water is everything it's
direct sex it's Xbox Live its
vlogbrothers it's funny flowing over to
the morgue wonderful good piece of
information the people who provide
internet access to you send you whatever
you want at the highest speed possible
for your plan unfortunately for me and
for the telecoms but fortunately for
everyone else my shower isn't the only
shower in the world
everyone has their information showers
on all the time bathing in the glory of
everything that is the Internet then
suddenly these telecom companies might
be unable to fulfill their promises for
how much water they can provide and at
this time running out of water they'll
have to pay money they'll have to make
investments to get more water or
bandwidth or whatever I'm talking about
the important thing is that it will cost
money and that will cut into their
profits so the telecom companies have
found their solution to this problem
their solution if they say what is
taking up all of this Internet bandwidth
and how can we make it stop
and what they figured out that 85% of
the bandwidth is being taken up by
BitTorrent and so they're like well
these people are thieves anyway let's
just turn down the knob some on what
they can do on the internet if there's a
little dribble a little dribble out of
the shower there this sounds fine for
like four seconds because those people
are breaking the law anyhow all the
telecoms are doing is making it harder
for thieves to steal well first it is
not the job of the telecom companies to
enforce the law and I think that that is
clear that we should not make it their
job second if they do do this what
happens when they start to run out again
when people are enjoying the Internet
legitimately and again the telecoms
start to run out of bandwidth what do
they cut next if bid tourism gobbling up
85 percent of the bandwidth what is
gobbling of 85 percent of the bandwidth
well probably it's it's YouTube one day
you'll be watching YouTube you'll say
why is it is measly drew why is it
taking me 45 minutes to watch Charlie
but on this Brewers finger and you're
frustrated and you're angry but then you
hear that Comcast comm has internet
videos that are coming in just fine and
faster than ever before YouTube I love
you but Comcast Comcast oh I was calling
hot very cold and then very hot
confusing on my by net neutrality is the
concept that Internet service providers
cannot decide what content I get at what
speeds they should not be able to turn
down the bandwidth for YouTube and turn
it up for comcast streaming cable they
should not be able to gouge content
creators like myself for their profit at
the expense of the entire world I'm
sorry to say this but if they are
legally able to do this they will do it
and it won't just kill YouTube it'll
kill the next thing the next amazing
cool thing that is even greater than
YouTube that we don't know what it is
yet but that has enormous economic
potential that thing won't exist because
they will have killed the amazing open
and innovative nature of the Internet
and suddenly what we'll have instead of
this infinite variety of crap is a
finite amount of crap and a finite
amount of crap is just crap whereas an
infinite amount of crap is hope all of
us can help make sure that the internet
remains a place where infinite amounts
of crap can be thrown at the wall and
some of it will stick go to save the
internet com read up on that neutrality
make sure you're educated and
participating in this debate John I will
see you on Friday I think I'm just gonna
take a shower now because I'm soaking
wet